i was waiting for you to smile at some
of the compliments you didn't they are
weaker smaller they are less intelligent
this is how we talk about women
the words that raise our girls and how
the media reflects women back to us but
where do these stereotypes come from and
how do they keep showing up and defining
our lives i'm megan and this is
archetypes meghan markle's newest role
podcaster let's talk about this for a
second that audio you just heard it's
from megan's new podcast archetypes it's
the first collab between the duchess and
hubby prince harry's company archwell
and spotify where they inked a
multi-year partnership you know they
grew this company during a pandemic and
this is their first real venture and
post-royal life and thus far it's it's
looking to be very successful so what's
the mom of two's focus for archetypes
the podcast where we dissect explore and
subvert the labels that try to hold
women back i'll have conversations with
women who know all too well how these
typecasts shape our narratives and i'll
talk to historians to understand how we
even got here in the first place this
series falls under the couple's deal
with spotify where they plan to put out
uplifting and entertaining original
content one of the things my husband and
i have always talked about is our
passion for meeting people and hearing
their stories and no matter what the
story they usually offer you an
understanding of where someone else is
coming from and at the same time remind
you in some way of a story about
yourself and that's what this project is
all about to bring forward different
perspectives and voices that perhaps you
haven't heard before and find our common
ground and that partnership is just one
of many they also have a multi-million
dollar deal with netflix to release
scripted series docu-series and even
children's programming so it seems megan
and harry are staying busy following
their decision to step down as senior
members of the royal family megan and
harry left the royal family to become
independent to become financially
independent they have absolutely
achieved that this year they have set
themselves up for what looks set to be
an exciting future their personal lives
are also thriving since stepping down
they bought a 14 million dollar
montecito mansion where they now live
with their two kids archie and lillabet
they are building a business model
america is their new home and netflix
spotify the deals that they are done are
their financial future the suggestion
that they're going to go back to the
royal family
simply isn't going to happen and with so
much change there could be some doubts
about the future but we're told the
sussexes are truly loving life don't
forget this is a prince who was born
despair who has always had to play
second fiddle to his brother i think
megan was the catalyst for a new life
for him she really gave him the
confidence to say okay there is another
way so what might have seemed daunting
terrifying even probably a year ago
because this has made no mistake in a
massive
leap of faith i think now looks like a
very exciting adventure for the couple i
don't think there are any regrets
[Music]
you